when i was 24 years old i saw the ufc
on a pay-per-view on tv and i was so
overwhelmed by the athleticism the skill
and then at the end of the fight the
combatants hugged they shook
hands and i just fell in love with it
part of
ufc's appeal is it doesn't look like a
balletic display of martial
talent and mastery as much as it looks
like a bar fight
we choose to do this because we love the
sport but it is a business
and if you do not treat it like a
business i guarantee you that the
promoter is
and you will be left broken broken at
the end of your career
each of us have an individual story but
as with anything you take enough of
these individual stories and you see
not only crossover but intersectionality
a group of former ufc fighters that are
suing the ufc
scored a key legal victory on thursday
when a federal judge said he would grant
their lawsuit clash action status
there have been fights in every major
u.s
sport about workers power in the labor
market
i don't think there's a guy in the sport
from the guy who just got his first
fight all the way up to the conor
mcgregors
that is pleased with the way the ufc
treats fighters the way we've been
strong-armed the way we've been coerced
fights over unionization in some sports
fights over free agency in baseball
and in boxing the muhammad ali act which
restricts the kinds of contract terms
that can be imposed on boxers the
fighters who brought this lawsuit see it
as the continuation
of a tradition in sports of athletes
fighting to have agency and power
in the terms of their work and who they
do it for
mixed martial arts used to be pretty
culturally and legally fringe in the
united states
it was banned by most states john mccain
had famously called it human [ __ ]
fighting
there are some rules in the ufc but to a
large extent
all sorts of body parts and tactics
and attacks are on the table and people
get
seriously injured at times my nose has
been broken multiple times
i had my right pectoral torn off how to
get that reattached
i've had my jaw broken in two places
i've had my neck broken
had my left ankle broken had to get that
repaired
i've had uh torn right labrum in my
shoulder
he broke my eyeball i mean the bone that
holds up my eyeball
i've had my left eye orbital fracture
twice where my eye caved in i was
swallowing my own blood and i knew
don't blow your nose or both eyes will
blow
at the time that ufc was bought for just
two million dollars by the
former boxing coach dana white and
a casino owner he'd been friends with
lorenzo fertitta
and his brother frank fertitta ufc was
struggling
as were other mixed martial arts
promoters
it was pretty much a fixer-upper the
money that they spent to actually
purchase it
for two million dollars was much less
than the money they quickly had to sink
into it
in order to revitalize it they've hold
off
a multi-pronged strategy that was quite
successful
first they did what white has referred
to as
running towards regulation they found
ways
to make compromises with state
regulators
so that the sport would not be illegal
and at the same time they also
popularized it
they made gambles like paying the
production costs themselves for the
first season of a reality tv show the
ultimate fighter on spike tv
[Applause]
ufc under dana white had a gift
for weaving compelling personal
narratives and
rivalries people throwing shoes
a guy coming to the octagon with who let
the dogs out playing while he was
dragging another guy on a leash
my first contract with the ufc is kind
of an interesting story because here i
am on this reality show the ultimate
fighter
and they started to realize how big of a
stepping stone this was going to be for
the ufc
sat us all down individually put a
contract in front of us
and said hey we realize that this is
going to be huge and we really want to
have you all a part of the
ufc family moving forward so we want to
go ahead and get this out of the way
just sign this simple contract and we'll
be able to move forward as one unit
but as i'm looking at this thick
contract and wondering what i should do
dana white looks at me and says don't
worry
this thing takes off we'll take care of
you
the fighters would say at the heart of
ufc's
power is the contract that it signs with
fighters before boxing had
competition boxing used to be dominated
by a few dominant promoters
and the contracts were ported over from
boxing and the contracts are basically
designed to control
every aspect of a fighter's career
they're long term they last
multiple fights fighters under these
contracts
are bound to fight only for ufc
for a period of time and ufc
can extend that time if a fighter
declines a match
or if a fighter gets injured they
control who the fighter fights
they control when the fighter fights and
then they have a number of different
clauses that make it very difficult
for a fighter to ever break free from
the ufc if that fighter ever did want to
become a free agent
contracts are so one-sided there really
is no negotiation room
for any of the things especially as
you're coming up and as their
stranglehold
on the sport of mma got so much stronger
part of what's at the heart of this
lawsuit is the ways that ufc
successfully took other competitors
off the board the ufc had such a
stranglehold on mixed martial arts and
as they were buying up so much of the
competition shutting them all down
they really became the the only option
for anybody that wanted to do this
professionally if you follow
dana white's twitter or watch him on
youtube
you could have seen dana white calling
himself the grim reaper
and bragging about how he has
defeated or derailed or acquired
one after another company that tried to
compete
with the ufc in 2011
ufc acquired strike force which at the
time was
the most prominent rival still standing
conley is unbelievable it was a great
fight that's here for him one more time
scott smith
and kong lee the ceo of strikeforce
scott coker
has said in the past that he saw himself
like luke skywalker
up against the death star trying to
compete with ufc
eventually when strikeforce was bought
out by ufc
my only option was to go to ufc because
they had the rest of my contract
now i'm under a contract where it's only
an 18 month
contract with six fights but five years
later i'm still accepting the contract
dana white president the month before
ufc's parent company
zuffa completed its acquisition of
strikeforce
a ufc executive sent an email
and the subject line of that email was
we own
mma and the ufc has admitted
in documents that have now become public
that they've almost never lost a fighter
that they wanted to keep
in internal ufc emails we now know
the company referred to what it was
doing as
choking off oxygen to the competition
the most important oxygen that ufc
allegedly ran afoul of the law by
cutting off to its competitors is the
fighters themselves
and not only did they make it clear to
us they made it clear to the whole mixed
martial arts world
there is no negotiating these are very
strict
never-ending contracts and that's the
case to this day
the ufc just says oh you want to fight
for us you sign here if you don't want
to we've got 20 other guys that'll take
your spot
they have 70 80 90 of the top fighters
under exclusive contract meaning that
those fighters are not available to any
other mma promoter
and fighters even if they wiggled their
way out of the very restrictive contract
that ufc imposed on them
didn't have another professional mixed
martial arts option
because there weren't robust rivals to
go
sell their work to on tuesday afternoon
a class action lawsuit was filed in u.s
district court in san jose against zuffa
llc with fighters kung lee
nate quarry and john fitch attached to
the suit rampage jackson
came to me says hey kung i know this
lawyer he will
help get some fairness for the fighters
on you know
in the marketplace and i decided i
wanted to
step up for all the fighters that's
being affected
at the end of 2014 more than six years
ago now
a group of now all former fighters
filed a antitrust class action lawsuit
against ufc
and in broad terms the case is an
antitrust case
where we're claiming that the ufc is
both a monopoly and a monopsony
usually when we talk about monopoly
we're talking about the power that a
company has
when it becomes the only one selling
something
monopsony is about the power of being
a monopoly purchaser of something and
particularly
a monopoly purchaser of labor
a key argument in this lawsuit has been
about
as ufc succeeds and its revenue soars
how much should we expect that absent
illegal conduct the fighters pay would
soar
as well in ufc year after year
the share of the company's revenue that
goes to actually
paying the workers doing the fighting
has hovered
around or below 20 and what this
analysis
shows through complex statistical uh
regression modeling is that if the ufc
was competitive and did not allegedly
violate the antitrust laws
it would pay its fighters 50
or more of the revenues it's generated
just like baseball just like hockey
just like basketball boxing if instead
of paying 20
of the revenues generated it paid 50 or
more of the revenues generated
the fighters would have made 1.6 billion
dollars more
during the period that we measured 2010
to 2017.
sometimes when you write about
allegations against
companies and particularly about
lawsuits against companies
those companies don't want to say a
whole lot
about them or are pretty dismissive of
the
significance of litigation against them
ufc
in their comments to me has been
pretty feisty about this saying that
they see this lawsuit
actually as a threat to the ability of
businesses to take risks and succeed
and that they don't want to roll over
that they want to fight it and they want
to defeat it
the fighters i talked to described
having side jobs
being reliant on ufc in part because
after taxes and expenses
they weren't making enough money to feel
financially secure
the overview of my career from a
financial perspective is
you know something i've had a challenge
in admitting i can tell you now that i
lived in my mom's natash garage the
entire time i was fighting and i had
a second job as a bouncer and a
bartender a third job as a personal
trainer
just to make ends meet nate quarry told
me that over his time in ufc
he fought fights while he was
tens of thousands of dollars in debt
coming into the fight
it gets so disheartening because i've
seen fights
that are called the fight of the year
this is just
this brutal war and they battled for
four and a half rounds until
one guy's body just gave up and then you
find out oh that guy made sixty thousand
dollars for that fight
in one of the hearings in this lawsuit
ufc's attorney argued that if the
fighters were
really the product if all that ufc were
selling were the fighters
then the fighters wouldn't need ufc at
all that
a fighter is not themselves the ufc
product any more than an
apple engineer who makes a cool iphone
is the product that apple is selling we
the fighters
make this whole thing happen and it's
been driven by chuck liddell it's been
driven by randy couture it's been driven
by conor mcgregor it's been driven by
brock lesnar it's been driven by all the
greats
that have walked before us and that walk
this path right now
we are the product if the fighters are
not the product
then go ahead and release us from our
contracts you'll do fine without us
clearly it's the identity and rank
and popularity of those fighters that
attract the eyeballs
and make the sport what it is and if you
can lock all those up and keep them from
other promotions you can dominate the
sport which is what they've admitted
they've
done william isaacson
a lawyer for ufc said in a statement
that ufc
has spent many years building a
world-class organization
enhancing the brand of our athletes and
championing the sport of mma
ufc pays its fighters more than any
other mma promoter with average fighter
compensation
rising by over 600 percent since 2005.
our efforts have raised the global
popularity of the sport
and the overall revenue potential of all
mma organizations
and athletes in december
of 2020 the judge
announced a crucial step in this lawsuit
which is that he is going to
certify it as a class action class
certification
makes this lawsuit a much more
significant threat
to ufc and the judge made clear
long before saying how he planned to
rule that he expected
whatever he did to be appealed into
federal appeals court and on from there
to the u.s supreme court so we are
likely in for
many more months and years of
wrangling over this
[Applause]
kyle kingsbury said that he doesn't
think any settlement would be acceptable
unless it includes a change to the
restrictive contracts
that ufc uses to keep fighters
bound to the ufc my son's about to turn
six years old and it started when he was
in the womb
you know we're in this thing to the end
to change the sport forever
we want the same freedoms that are
offered in any other major sport and
we're
every other major sport has gone through
what we're going through right now
people tell fighters you know just shut
up
look at how lucky you are well no
actually
we're fighting for what we believe in
we're going to continue being fighters
and that's how we
how we're made
you